Media Molecule brought out something
that was really and I just want to talk
about it for a minute because there
wasn't a lot to grab on to you know is
very like oh yeah you just like you can
paint anything and it could be a person
and you could tell that the or a bear or
a bad person with a bear head just sort
of this like creative palette kind of
yeah it seems like they like we've
created this canvas for you just go wall
with amin we predicted that Media
Molecule would be on the stage with
something weird and they did show up
with something I'd weird like the stuff
that he was drawing was like that thing
looks kind of ugly but at the same time
it's kind of fascinating to look at I
mean it's an interesting idea and it's
kind of in their territory where they're
you know creating worlds for people to
explore and share and that kind of thing
it's just a lot like little big planet
but this dream verse which they're
talking about is quite interesting i
want to see more of it it's weird it's
one of those annoying developer things
whether like I know you have questions
yeah but that's the whole point it's
going by a question it's like one he
just explained it to me but in a way it
doesn't even feel like a game it's like
media molecules peyote simulators just
like it because I guess making the thing
is the game but like terms of game
played very much see it's almost like a
machinima tool or something yeah shows
not yeah but it's it's got you know
you've got meaty molecule has experience
obviously with creation tools
littlebigplanet you know and then you
have other tons of creation tools in
gaming garry's mod of course one of them
but this doesn't look like anything else
is this is the biggest reduced its its
it seems like once once you see like how
different you things you can create just
immediately brings to mind microsoft
project spark thing yeah which is like
this is Sony clearly Sony's answer to
project spark which is kind of awesome
like everyone giving people the chance
to create something and you know share
it and that kind of stuff it's always
welcome because I mean project spark is
way to create in for a lot of people but
the stuff that's in days some of is
really fascinating and I'm just so
excited to see this these kind of
creation sweets uh dreams it looks like
trying to be freed from the shackles of
a unifying aesthetic like it doesn't all
look the same which was the big planets
problem was that everything just looked
like little big club
super cute but what if you're not like
feeling super cute feeling like a bear
beheaded pianist with a raven bursted in
a birds like this just seems like the
emotional palette for creativity could
be so much broader